a ton of questions but i guess the the
thing is what are you most excited for
people to actually see in the rings of
power to me
to tell you the truth
i will be very excited if people is
excited again about middle earth
because being such a fan of talking
books
um
i think all the values that you can find
in those books are so needed nowadays so
we can get people excited and go back to
the books and read them or discover them
that would be fantastic you are making
essentially a prequel to you know lord
of the rings and the hobbit how much did
you look at those movies for inspiration
as like your visual guide and how much
are you sort of saying well this is
happening
so much before that time we need to do
something completely different or do you
know what i mean yeah totally you know
what when i think about the peter
jackson movies the thing i love them and
the thing that i admire the most
is how great he was in capturing
talking to spirit
so at the end it's all about going to
the source material and and go to the
books
you know so so i this is what i did i i
went back to the books i read them again
and everything is in there
you can tell
how cinematic
talking was when the way he portrays the
landscape
reflects the mood of the characters you
know that's the kind of um
style that i love when i when i when i
shoot a movie i try all the time to
enhance the story with visual elements
and that sense of beauty for example
from the very beginning i knew that the
cinematographer i always worked with
was perfect because
he loves beauty as much as you can see
when you read tolkien's books
and from the moment you choose the
cinematographer
you are defining the style of the of the
show you know uh
so basically it was going back to the to
the books and try to understand them and
how they will translate visually
and exactly as you said it's a very
different time period so you really need
to go back to those places but you will
see them in a very different way for
fans of lord of the rings uh what do you
think will surprise people to learn
about the actual making of the rings of
power
uh i think what i think is very exciting
is
is that you don't know really the story
you know it's like because from the
appendixes we we have the main events
and in that sense you have the
impression that you're working in
something solid
that
is faithful to the to the spirit of
talking because talking design it
himself but then you have the storylines
that feel new and fresh
and in that sense was exciting
i think
what i
really like about what patrick and jd
teach me about the
the the whole five seasons was the
complexity
that things are not black and white
there's lots of gray areas you know in
that sense it's closer to lord of the
rings not the hobbit you know it feels
more mature i mean how would you
describe the scale and scope of the
series well it's like when you read the
books again i mean that sense of beauty
this sense of epic that you will you you
have you know the the way portrays uh
landscape i we try to get the biggest
canvas possible you know so we use the
the scope um the cinema scope in order
to get that sense that same sense of
epic that you have when you read the
books i it's a very ambitious show
but it's like
the biggest monumental
feat in literature in the 20th century
you know so so i think that i'm kind of
like
grateful that amazon
really had the ambition to put all these
resources in order to
to give the audience what they are
expecting
i am also willing to say thank you to
prime video for making this show i could
not be more excited um what what is your
do you have a favorite moment from the
original trilogy i think i think
i think there's a very beautiful moment
when uh
at the end of the return of the king
everybody kneels in front of the hobbits
and the camera kneels in front of them
so peter jackson basically what he did
is the whole world to kneel in in front
of the hobbies i think that was
beautiful first of all i agree with you
that's one of my favorite moments in in
in all the movies but it's interesting
how you point out that the camera went
down as well that is a director talking
exactly no and to me that that was the
kind of approach that i that i had with
patrick and jd the thing is that if you
think about talking
the basics of his universe was the
language so he created characters
uh
coming from from the language so he
created elvis before the elves and and
then he created the world where these
elves were living you know to me as a
director is also about the language so
if i have a good understanding of the
story
and the characters i know where to place
the camera and there's only one possible
position for the camera
in order to reflect the psychology of
the characters and and the moment you're
portraying
so to me there's not a difference
between making a tv show or a movie and
in that sense i rely in
my language which is not based on words
but more on the camera
how much of the sundering c sequence was
practical and how much was added via vfx
we had a huge water tank huge and it was
very very very hard to work uh it's
always very hard to work in the water so
to communicate with the actors they were
so far away from the video village you
know it was a huge huge step one of the
things that i noticed looking at the
pictures was you used the tank had walls
but you were using natural light to
light the actors and i think that is
going to make the sequence look so much
better because you're not faking the
light you know they're really on the
water can you sort of talk about why you
wanted the natural light in the scene
well you you need to thank oscar farah
the cinematographer that was uh
that was his fight
so he was trying to convince everybody
that we needed to shoot with natural
light especially if you are and ex if
you finally extend this we did a lot of
that in the impossible when we shot the
impossible if you extend the set it's
very difficult if you if you work uh
indoors because you cannot match the
light from the from the outside with the
with the with the inside the artificial
light with the with the light that we
had on on the studio so we we he fight a
lot and actually we designed a water
tank made in the outside that was
supposed to be functioning not only for
daytime but also for nighttime so we had
to cover that with huge tanks it was a
massive endeavor but the
it they definitely delivers it pays off
when you see the the scenes you will see
how beautiful they are how long did it
actually take you to film the sequence
we spent a long time in the water i
there were several sequences shot in
there in the sundering seas yeah i think
we have like
like four or five sequences in there and
it took us probably like around two
weeks three weeks two weeks what's the
biggest feeling you want the audience to
take away from in terms of the sundering
seas beyond being able to glimpse this
never before um seen location for the
first time
i i really like the idea of
you know
the every the landscape is so symbolic
in in talking you know and when you read
his books you know like so you find this
character that's that is kind that
galatrial is so so lost at the beginning
of our story and you will find them in
the center of the sundering seas you
know and there are some surprises in
there i don't want to spoil
any of them but
some things are moving in the underneath
in there you know and it it's it's fun
it's a lot of fun but it reflects the
psychology of the moment you know it
reflects where the character is and what
the situation is not only in that but in
general i know you're a huge lord of the
rings fan and i know you love tolkien um
what did it mean to you to be able to
bring
uh this location to life for the first
time in live action to me it's pure joy
because i i share with talking the same
idea of fantasy and how fantasy can
portray reality better than reality
itself you know i think fantasy
sometimes it's difficult for us to
recognize things if we have them right
in front of us and you need some
distance and i think fantasy gives you
that distance it's kind of like a
deformed mirror where you can see
yourself better
you know and in that sense i love that
idea of fantasy because there's always
uh
a psychology involved on it it it refers
to a real feeling and a real emotion and
in that sense it feels very truthful it
feels very very very real you mentioned
it a second ago but what can you tease
about what hypothetically could be in
the water
next question
we enjoy that those sequences we enjoy
them a lot
and
and it's
i think people will find what they are
expecting hopefully one of the things
that i'm getting the vibe on is that
this wasn't really like making a tv show
at all like making this series was
making like an eight-hour movie is that
the case yeah totally that's what i was
referring when when i talked to patrick
and jd
that to me was all about bringing the
cinematic
kind of like style that we love from the
movies to the to the television you know
and i think television is evolving a lot
right now it's not the same television
that we used to see when we were kids uh
and it's getting more close uh it's
closer to
to the to the movies when you talk about
um with the sundering season you built
this outdoor
stage if you will how much how much
debate was going on behind the scenes in
terms of can we afford to build this for
just a few sequences like what is it
like trying to negotiate with like your
line producer and with the production
and where you want to spend money well
we had we had this money and and we had
to measure they would they they
mentioned all the time about how big is
the production but we have we had a
limit so at the end it's about measuring
your resources
we had a
[Music]
long section of episode two and part of
of episode one in the sundering seas so
it was worth it at the end to spend the
money in there
but always it's it's all a negotiation
all the time you have a limit and it's
good to have a limit because if you
don't have a limit
uh is that is then when you get lost i
have also spoken to a lot of filmmakers
and they say once you reach the wall
you become so much more resourceful on
how to climb the wall exactly yeah
and when you know your limitation is a
lot easier to design the work you to
have a plan um what was actually the
hardest part of filming the sundering
seas sequences
i mean it's always very hard to work on
on water
in the water uh
everything it's like
everything is so slow
to move the actors to talk to them
uh
the light you know the way you need to
measure the light to match with the with
the post-production you know
uh if you have
everything has to be attached
you cannot have the actors on top of a
raft
moving around so every and if you want
to move the raft
then it takes some time to put it in the
position that you want so everything
becomes so slow
that
it makes your work a lot harder than
being in
in a normal stage what was it like for
you in the editing room when you start
looking at the footage from the
sundering seas were you immediately like
oh my god this was so worth it um you
know what what was it like editing that
stuff well the thing is that the
the set was so big
that
the material that we
got in in the editorial
didn't need that much of post-production
you know there were some
effects
added but they were more about adding
mist and things like that
because uh
and that's very helpful when you have a
sh when you when you in your your screen
you have all the information that you
need makes your ho makes you work a lot
easier when i saw the pictures i saw the
cameras they were huge and i'm curious
what cameras did you end up using to
film your episodes and why
you know when we were using the we were
using the same cameras
uh but the thing is that you need to
protect them because if they get if they
if they get wet then then we will have a
problem no so uh we are using all these
carcasses
that protects the camera and they and
they are very very heavy
big
again makes your work very slow you know
and there were different kinds of
carcasses so there was there was those
ones that
were able to get into the water the ones
that were able to get a little wet but
not much and and then the cameras that
were not able to get into
into the water you know so it's it's all
like a big puzzle
you know and and you need to have a very
good plan in order to keep the shoot
moving fast is it one of these things
where when you're filming a sequence
like that you are using like five
cameras or three cameras like how many
cameras do you like do you like to shoot
with when you're doing like a water
sequence like that in in general i
normally like to work with one camera to
me there's like a
like the main shot and sometimes uh i
get a secondary shot maybe a third
but never more than that and these shots
normally
i it's it's just because if we get
something serious interesting we will
use them but to me it's basically all
about the main camera i saw in the
pictures that you guys were using these
almost cranes
to make the waves and um can you sort of
talk about uh
like making fake waves and how you did
that yeah actually i i
i remember the first time we were
testing them they look fantastic i mean
they and we we have these giant
vehicles that were able to push the
water and increase the level you know
and and we were able to
to play with different sizes of the of
the waves
um
and it looked fantastic i i was very
very surprised that
we shot the nighttime scenes during
daytime
and they look fantastic
even with my telephone i was able just
to
like playing with my telephone i was
able to to look at it we we shot a huge
um
storm in the water and you will be
very surprised when you'll see it
because that was shot during the daytime
one of the things i'm curious you've
obviously been directing for a long time
can you talk a little bit about how vfx
has come along over the last say five
years and what it's
any like new things that have happened
that have helped you as a storyteller to
be able to tell you know your stories in
the in the last years i mean you can do
everything with visual effects right now
i mean if you can imagine you can do it
the thing is that
what is what are you looking for with
that visual effect you know it's not to
rely just rely just on the visual
effects is
why
what are you trying to
tell what is the story you're trying to
tell with the visual effects you know
and in the last years there were a lot
of
different tools that uh had
that has that that gave us a lot of help
in trying to especially to previous
visualize the stories you know that that
but for example i'm going to tell you an
example uh there were there is a lot of
motion control shots
you know because we need to play with
the scale different scales uh in between
characters in the same shot you know so
one of the things that i mentioned to
the visual effects guys is that one of
the things that i don't like about the
motion control shots is that
they are so smooth they are they they
feel mechanic you know they they feel
like rigid i recognize when when you're
doing when i see a movie when it's a
motion control shot because
the camera moves moves always in in this
kind of way that i can recognize it you
know and i i asked the visual effects
guys can we can we do a motion control
shot
but with a handheld camera and they say
no
but maybe we can invent something and
three weeks after that they came to me
and said well this is your camera you
can move it
and then the camera will replace
replicate the same
movement that you did and i was like wow
that was fantastic
what is it like to edit a series like
this is it like editing a feature film
in terms of the amount of time or could
you sort of talk a little bit about that
in this case we we have to stop for
covet
like halfway through the shoot we
stopped for covet and that gave us like
six months
to be working in the edit not of the of
the whole two episodes
but like half of it
uh
and that was like a good relief because
when you work on television you have
very limited time for the for to deliver
the cab but that gave us um
an extra time that was very helpful for
the process and that no need to stop i
am tremendously looking forward to
talking to you about specifics at some
point down the road i wish you nothing
but the best
you